Speaker 1: And you know what? While we're talking
about some of the stupidest things imaginable
that a human being can say. Let's talk about
Herschel Walker. Right. Herschel Walker this week
came out in his opposition to the Inflation
Reduction Act at home. So sorry. It's so
hard to keep a straight face and do this
sometimes. And he said that, you know,
we don't need additional spending on environmental
issues because aren't there enough trees already?
Let me read let me read his exact statement.
They continue to try to fool you that
they're helping out, but they're not
because a lot of money, it's go into trees.
Don't we have enough trees around here?
Climate change saw folks were done. Pack it
up. Environmentalists, we've had a great run,
but Herschel Walker just exposed the whole thing.
There's there's already trees out there. They've
seen the trees, folks. What are we going to do?
They know the trees exist. Look, look, look.
I don't. I don't want to be just exceptionally
hard on Herschel Walker, okay? I know he has had
a difficult life. He has openly talked about, you
know, mental problems that he has had. And I do
not want to pile on to that. And I do not want to,
you know, act like an able list here at all. What
I will say, however, with regard to policy is that
this statement is unfortunately not an aberration.
These are the kinds of things that conservatives
say to get you to think that any action to protect
the environment, to make the climate not hit that
point of no return is stupid. Right in their eyes,
we are the stupid ones because we want to
protect the planet. We are the stupid ones
because we don't want to kill 1400 people
a year in the United States alone with air
pollution. We are crazy for thinking that
that. My God, what if we just made things
better for people? That makes us the weirdos.
Know somebody who's going out there saying,
we got enough trees out here. What are we doing?
That's the weirdo. The weirdoes are the ones who
bring snowballs onto the floor of the Senate in
wintertime and say, Well, climate change is done.
We are witnessing right now in this
country today. Look out your dang windows.
You see climate change. If you're in Texas, you're
seeing it firsthand. If you're in Colorado and
California, you're seeing it firsthand.
Down here in Florida, we're seeing it
firsthand. New Orleans seeing it firsthand and
countless other places all across the country.
A couple more trees here and there isn't going
to solve it. And no, by the way, for the record,
we do not have enough trees out there either.
But Herschel Walker is carrying on in that long
Republican tradition of denying that climate
change exists and then trying to reduce it
to its most ridiculous form. Listen, that's
all the time we have for today. We've got a
wonderful member's only bonus show coming up
for you in just a little bit. But if you want
more from me, Farron Cousins, you can find
me YouTube.com slash the Ring of Fire. I'm
also at YouTube.com slash fair and balanced. And
I'm Twitter, Instagram and Facebook at Fair and
Balanced. Thank you so much for tuning in. This
is the David Pakman show. We'll see you next time